Che poi lo volete sapere qual è il problema? EH EH
Che a loro non gli bastava essere felici e contenti durante tutto l'anno, no si so inventati pure la festa degli innamorati per farci rosicare ancora di più, per farci sentire più soli!
E voi siete pronti alle foto tutte uguali di San Valentino, tutte uguali! Cena a lume di candela,
mazzo di rose, bacino e la frase tristissima che l'accompagna
Che ti prego Dio salvami non le voglio vedere!
Per me San Valentino
è una serara come tutte le altre,
schifezze, serie tv,
e tanta, tanta depressione.
Ma basta con questa storia di San Valentino che bisogna festeggiare a San Valentino. Io col mio moroso
festeggio tutti i giorni. Ci
ritagliamo sempre quella giornata
tutta per noi, quel momento nostro dolce, romantico.
Eh è così quando si è innamorati, si è sempre felici
si ha sempre voglia di festeggiare.
ma ci rendiamo conto che mi ha lasciato il giorno prima di San Valentino
con un messaggio
cos'è? Voleva risparmiare sui cioccolatini lo stronzo?
"no, non sei tu, sono io..."
"sei tu che sei troppo perfetta..." Ma vaffa...!
Ogni anno, a San Valentino, io e  le mie amiche ci vediamo a casa di una di noi
e...
chiaccherando
e mangiando schifezze
ci chiediamo perché nessuno ce se piglia così ci sentiamo meno sole, ecco
Peccato che quest'anno
Non so perché per...
Si sono fidanzate tutte
Sono l'unica single
ma che vuoi che me ne frega di San Valentino
Il 14 Febbraio è un giorno più speciale... E' il mio compleanno!
Certo Marti che l'ha capito. Sono tre mesi che gli faccio vedere quella borsa
ogni volta che passiamo lì davanti quella vetrina, cioè, è palese... Eh
Io non gliel'ho ancora preso il regalo
Non so cosa regalargli, sono in panico totale
Io San Valentino l'ho sempre amato però quest'anno c'è la sessione esami quindi
Ciao proprio, non si festeggia mica eh
E lo chiedi pure? Certo che mi piacerebbe festeggiarlo San Valentino
ma sto con uno che odia il romanticismo, odia San Valentino che deve fa' i regali
e sapete cosa fa la sera di San Valentino?
Lui si deve vedere la Champions, io non ho parole! Non ho parole
Io proprio non riesco a capire
come si possa odiare San Valentino
Ma è la festa più bella dell'anno! E non vedo l'ora che arrivi San Valentino, perché proprio
lo respiri nell'aria l'amore, lo senti, lo percepisci
E' tutto così tremendamente romantico
che bello
Peccato che sono single
da una vita
Sento in continuazione ragazze lamentarsi perché sono single
Allora, partendo dal presupposto che i problemi sono altri nella vita,
essere single non è un difetto, non è un problema
Io sono single ma sono serena, io non
mi accontento, sicuramente, di qualcuno
soltanto perché ho paura di stare sola
Bisogna imparare a bastarsi, bisogna imparare a stare da soli
e non c'è niente di male in questo
*canzone outro*